rompió su pasaporte en el último minuto
para evitar su expulsión de belarús
maría kolésnikova la destacada opositora
bielorrusa fue detenida el lunes por un
grupo de encapuchados durante las
masivas protestas en contra del
mandatario alexandr lukashenko pasó
horas desaparecida hasta que durante la
madrugada del martes funcionarios del
gobierno vestidos de civil la condujeron
a la frontera con ucrania junto a otros
dos opositores en un intento por
deportar los del país bajo ecuación
[Música]
en cuanto subió al coche y vio su
pasaporte lo tomo inmediatamente y lo
rompió en muchos pedazos pequeños
y bueno
los lanzó por la ventana a los
desconocidos que rodeaban el coche
después de eso abrió la ventanilla dejó
el auto por la ventana trasera y se
dirigió hacia la frontera con belarús
sus compañeros del consejo de
coordinación de la perseguida oposición
si cruzaron la frontera y se encuentran
en kiev mientras que las autoridades
bielorrusas alegan que kolésnikova fue
arrestada cuando intentaba cruzar la
frontera ilegalmente la opositora es la
única de la troika de mujeres que
plantaron cara al mandatario en los
comicios de hace un mes que decidió no
exiliarse pese a las amenazas
joe todavía no sabemos dónde está y si
es verdad pero si es así yo estoy
realmente sur de sí
estoy muy orgullosa de maría sí es
verdad que no dejo que la echaran del
país es una mujer valiente este martes
el polémico presidente lukashenko dijo a
los periodistas rusos que no descartaría
la celebración de nuevas elecciones pero
rechazó el diálogo con la oposición y el
rechazo si lukachenko colapsa hoy todo
el sistema se derrumbaría y belarús
colapsaría a su vez belarús vive un
tenso estancamiento político desde las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado 9
de agosto con los manifestantes
inundando las calles denunciando fraude
y una brutal respuesta policial